I'm joined now by the president of
Israel Isaac hog Mr President thank you
very much indeed for joining me uh I
appreciate you're obviously very busy at
the moment and I I appreciate you taking
the time to talk to us let me start by
uh taking you back to October the 7th
the day that was a catalyst for this new
war where were you that day and when did
you hear about what had
happened it was say 6:30 in the morning
I was plan
to wake up at around 7:30 because it was
a holiday a Saturday and a vacation
actually the entire week before was a
national vacation because it was the
Feast of
Tabernacles and um I was planning to go
to synagogue to celebrate the new
opening of the Bible as we read each
week a portion of the Bible and so it
was
Genesis and um silence broke the silence
in the entire neighbor neighborhood were
Torn to Pieces by immense sirens and
then booms and Booms and Booms we
immediately realized that we are under
missile attack it was a huge missile
attack in highsight we know that there
was well over 2,000 missiles launched at
all of Israel from Gaza and the shock
was huge but we thought we ran to the
shelters but we didn't know whether
there was anything else we assumed okay
Miss I attack for some reason I was
telling my wife there's a missile attack
and um then we opened the TV and
starting getting the news endless news
about atrocities all throughout our
Southern border about people being
locked in in shelters and burnt and and
and and under attack and they call they
call the emergency services they call
the uh Studios of Television they speak
to the Anchorman who on the on TV say
save us help us help us we're we're
under attack we're being booked we hear
the enemy we hear Arabic behind the door
etc etc and whole hell broke loose we've
gone through the worst atrocity as a
nation since the establishment of the
state of Israel the highest amount of
Jews killed since the Holocaust about
eight or nine times 911 in terms of our
national proportion of casualties but it
doesn't end end the cup is filled with
poison it doesn't end we feel we meet
families all the time you know I met the
uh go the almog Goldstein family you
have three
generations grandparents parents
children and many abducted and also
killed and missing and it goes on and on
and on all the
time you read a piece in the New York
Times about this and you talked about
going to one of the kabut which were
attacked and how you had to wash blood
off your shoes and how the meetings you
had with the families of those who've
been taken hostage were the most
difficult meetings of your life tell me
about
that so I went to ber kibutz by the way
the kibuts ber Bears the name of the
founder of the labor movement in Israel
B Katan netson that was his nickname and
ber was always looked to me as a as a
heaven I would go there because I was
leader of Labor I loved coming to Barry
it's a huge kibuts the idea of kibo is
the real epitomization of the successful
of socialism in modern times meaning
everybody shares everything we you don't
get an independent salary you remember
the kibuts you enjoy from the income of
the collective and they had an immense
industry of printing press and
Agriculture and things were looking so
beautiful and we would come there they
having dinners and lunches together in
the in in in the same dining room and it
looked like an
incredible Society to me like a a vision
never come true of what equal life
should mean in MO for human beings but
in in any case um in ber when I went in
to see the Havoc the atrocities the
burning homes in one of the homes when I
walked in there was a pool of blood
still drying there were sculps there was
a woman's sculps with a rake holding it
that shows how atrocious these people
were how villains they are how crazy
animalistic and barbaric and sadistics
they are and you walk and the the the
house is totally ruined but you see a
picture of grandparents and parents and
children in hanging on the security room
where they had this their shelter and
the shelter was of course totally burnt
and I assume there one of the burning
bodies there I mean families were tied
up in barred wies and burned together I
could only think what they said to the
almighty before they parted Earth and
then I I went and I since then I keep on
meeting families of the hostages endless
stories why would k a nemon old baby be
hijacked now he's already 10 his
grandmother told us sorry he's 10 months
old okay why would Leah three month 3
years old be hijacked where all her
family is being killed they just took
her and so forth and so on endless
stories of atrocities on the one hand
and the worst of all is not kn knowing
the fate of your loved one on the other
hand a clear crime against humanity
clear genocide took place in that area
incidentally the biggest peace loving
area in Israel where the center of the
peace movement was one of our friends
Vivian silver she's from very she's was
born in Canada Vivien was the biggest
leader of Peace in Israel she created a
an NGO called a AJ i c a is Arab Jews
Arabs and Jews together working for
peace B had a special fund Pierce a
special fund where they would allot
their
money to help the people of Gaza they
had a fund that paid well for for the
people of Gaza they had members who
would drive to the border to take gazin
to to to be hospitalized and treated in
Israeli medical centers they would bring
food to the to the fence and give them
food and I'm asking them now do you
really feel that you know who you can
trust anymore when I met that shattered
Community now as refugees in the Dead
Sea in a hotel when 10% of their members
have been totally annihilated killed
butchered chopped burnt these are the
real questions we'll have to face your
father himim who later became president
of Israel and in fact you're the only
father and son to ever achieve that
highest office um he was in the British
Army in World War II as an intelligence
officer in the armored formations he
fought the Nazis he took part in the
Normandy invasion he helped liberate
Holland and Belgium amongst other things
he helped capture Heinrich himler one of
the main architects of the Holocaust he
took pardon the liberation of the Bergen
bellson concentration camp and he talked
about when he when he was at bellson uh
telling the survivors he was a Jewish
officer from Palestine and how they
burst into tears at this and you have
said before I'll never forget how he
described to me the horrors that
unfolded before his eyes as one of the
first liberators of the death camps
including ber and bsum the human
skeletons in the Striped Pajamas the
hell on Earth the stench the Heart of
Darkness and you were asked once what
advice you thought your father would
give to Future generations and you said
never take the state of Israel for
granted did did you ever imagine when
your father was telling you these
stories that you yourself would walk
into a scene like you did in that Kutz
which was so reminiscent of the horrors
of the
Holocaust thank you for reminding this
to me it's quite moving for me because
my dad always spoke about these
moments my father joined the British
Army in order to fight the Nazis he was
a student in in at
Cambridge and the war broke out he also
served as a in the blitz within you know
in London the as guarding the streets he
always spoke about the immense
resilience of the British people under
constant attacks and then of course
wrote to his parents that he's joining
the British army to fight the Nazi enemy
and and save Jews and his experience in
Bergen bellson which was the one of the
greatest horrors of humanity there were
piles of bodies of skeletons Dead
skeletons there they has he depicted the
the awful smell of the atrocities at
burken bellson and the fact that when he
walked in truly the the survivors they
thought that he's a Nazi
perpetrator when and he had to turn them
to them in in Hebrew and Yiddish which
is a Jewish German language to tell them
I'm a Jewish officer from the land of
Israel coming to save you and there are
still Jews in the world so that's why it
was imprinted in his being and that's
how he passed it on to me and our to our
families never take the Jewish state for
granted this is our safe haven that's
where Jews from all over the world from
well over 100 countries came forward and
reestablished the anci Homeland and it's
an incredible country because not only
do we have Jews from well over 100
Nations originating from there but also
we have non-jews we have many Muslims
and Christians and Jews of all
denominations and chians and we all live
together in peace and solidarity despite
the tensions of the conflicts around us
or the conflict that we have with our
neighbors the truth is people don't know
but the these barbaric sadistic
terrorists they killed dozens and dozens
of Muslims on the 7th of October they
big they killed bedwin bedwin Arab
citizens of Israel who went to work I
had I went to meet last week the
families the beving families of Muslims
who were killed and abducted and are H
in Gaza and one of the C the the guys
there was a father of nine children he
went with his wife to work these
terrorists they stopped him on the road
and he said to them I'm a Muslim they
didn't give it down they broke the car
they immediately shot at his wife the
mother of nine again and again and again
and he described to me how he prayed to
go to God to Allah and bidding farewell
from his wife so it this tragedy has
befallen so many many people from so
many backgrounds from 36
nationalities and and the lesson I took
from my father is never never again Jews
will not accept the Jewish state will
not accept these atrocities within its
borders killing its citizens and we have
complained and and said and mentioned
endlessly to the world that we are under
Terror attacks
constantly almost 10,000 Miss were
launched at us since we pulled out of
Gaza in 2007 all from Hamas we've we've
alerted the entire universe and the
family of Nations that there's an Empire
of evil from Teran emanating with a
whole culture of hate to eradicate all
of us and I say to my friends all over
the world especially in Europe guys if
it weren't for us Europe would be next
because the culture of hate that these
guys have brought forward Isis alqaeda
Hamas and Islamic Jihad and the htis in
Yemen and the entire culture of hate
simply wants all of us out they don't
accommodate Jews Christians or even
moderate Muslims they are seeing the
inclusion of Israel in the region a
vision of Peace which we all believe in
as a threat to them and most importantly
they are want all they want is to chop
our heads and get to you guys next this
is the real challenge of the world today
one of the most extraordinary things to
witness uh as a non-jew I'm an Irish
Catholic looking at all this but within
hours of what happened uh there were
Mass protests all around the world from
New York to Sydney where there were
people chanting Gast to Jews in Sydney
one of the great cities of the world in
London there were protests in my High
Street up near the Israeli Embassy Mass
protests with many people celebrating
what had happened and I found that
unconscionable that any human being's
first reaction to this appalling terror
attack would be one of Jubilation we
then saw us professors at American
universities one at Cornell caught on
camera saying how exhilarated he felt by
what had happened we've seen students
again in American universities beaming
pramas rhetoric onto campus walls we've
seen Jewish students barricading
themselves in libraries for fear of
their safety from from chanting mobs and
in these protests in in London in New
York and others many many people there
at Pro Palestinian protest chanting
Jihad and from The River To The Sea when
you see all this as a reaction to this
ort in attack on Israel how does that
make you
feel you know I was talking to my wife
the other day I still remember September
93 in September 193 13th September there
was a ceremony at the White House
lawn but where prime minister Rabin and
the leader of the Palestinian national
movement Yas Arafat shook hands under
the hospices of President Clinton and
signed the osw Accords or started them
and there was and the entire nation was
watching it and I was telling then my
wife we had a baby we had two babies
this you know what perhaps our children
will not have to
fight well that reality has been shuted
long
ago and we understand that we always
will have to fight and and um as opposed
to um previous generations we have now
the state of Israel and we have the
tools to fight and Jews can fight all
over the world Jews are threatened I
have friends from all corners of the
earth people I grew up with I studied
with they are extremely frightened and
and and I have friends including one of
your most distinguished colleagues who
was in Israel last week told me I feel
much safer in Israel he's Jewish
now this is unacceptable because history
teaches us that anti-Semitism is always
the beginning but the tragedies unfold
to all other human beings this is the
greatest disease of humanity
anti-Semitism is the greatest disease of
humanity what these people are chanting
is not only immoral and notjust but it's
reflection of their own knowledge of
things or their own moral compass how
could you justify truly how could you
justify chopping children's heads how
could you
justify burning entire Families how
could you justify raping women of all
ages and taking them hostage how could
you justify tearing off people's women's
and men's sculps how could you justify
these horrific atrocities broadcast
broadcasting live how you carry out
these
atrocities taking a mother's iPhone and
broadcasting to the entire her entire
WhatsApp group how you are torturing her
husband or killing her daughter and and
her and her B and her young children and
this goes on and on and on this is a
test for Humanity and a moral call for
moral Clarity and human beings and
leaders must be outraged and understand
that when you give a nation the right
for self-defense it has a right for
self-defense meaning you have to get to
this um barbaric sadistic regime you
have to catch them you have to remove
them in order by the way
to
enable the people on our neighbors
perhaps to get rid of that awful regime
and most
importantly be very firm as to what's
evil and what's good we are fighting for
good we saw evil in our eyes we are
beving because of evil we are in agony
because of evil we must stand up against
evil with no mercy and make sure that we
overcome as a family of Nations because
the entire world order is at risk the
American congresswoman Rashida TB
tweeted from the river to the sea is an
aspirational call for Freedom human
rights and peaceful coexistence not
death destruction or hate what is your
response to
that she simply above everything else I
mean all these atrocious comments all
this terrible view of
things she simply doesn't know
history the world recognized the Jewish
State's rights for Independence in dece
in November
1947 in the UN General Assembly the
family of Nations accepted they are our
borders were of course agreed that
border was
violated by this terror attack and we've
strived for peace all throughout since
then we've extended our hands for peace
we signed peace agreement we defended
ourselves we fought for peace we were
willing to go for peace
but unfortunately the entire culture of
hate the culture of jihad Jihad may I
remind you about John jihadist who
simply would show the entire world how
he takes a prisoner and cuts his head
that's what Jihad is all about when
people chant not a revolutionary moment
when people chant from The River To The
Sea what does that mean to
you that that means annihilating Israel
because we have the Jordan River and the
Mediterranean Sea this is of course a
call to annihilate the state of Israel
the only nation state of the Jewish
people on Earth the Jewish people have
founded this state after returning to
their ancient Homeland rebuilding it and
re being recognized by the International
Community
unfortunately following the worst
atrocity of humanity which is the
Holocaust where six million of our
people were burnt gassed killed and
tortured and and killed by all sorts of
the most terrible means when in in in
the most violent attack Humanity has
seen where whereby the forces of good
led by the United States of America by
the British and the United Kingdom of
course by the USSR in those days they
all and together with all other nations
had to fight the Nazis and their allies
and liberate Europe and that brought the
change in the world that brought the
creation of the United Nations that led
to the human rights Charter that brought
to the uh definition of what genocide is
all about and crimes against humanity
well a new world order was created well
the world order is being challenged and
challenged
dramatically and this is the real
challenge in facing all leaders of the
world guys don't be mistaken you have to
be tough and strong to fight this evil
on Saturday it's armist day in uh the UK
a very important day where we obviously
commemorating on of those who sacrificed
their lives in in the wars um your
father undoubtedly would have lost
people that were close to him when he
served in the World War II uh how do you
feel about the fact there was a pro
Palestinian March a big one planned to
take part take place on Saturday on
armis day in London there are calls here
from many people now for this march to
be banned because many of the people
Marching In These marches have been
chanting Jihad from The River To The Sea
and other things like
that it's a atrocious and
hypocritic and I call upon all all
decent human beings to object to the
March and ban it because the symbol of
that day is a symbol of Victory and it's
it's a symbol of doing good because when
you fight evil sometimes you have to
fight you have to fight evil in order to
uproot evil unfortunately we live with
evil throughout the ages and um what we
are seeing constantly is unbelievable
evil
unbelievable evil we've seen Terror
we've been harassed by Terror all our
lives terror is what stopped the Israeli
Palestinian peace a terror is what
undermines peace we were in a historic
process for the last 50 years of
inclusion of Israel in the region of
peace agreements with Egypt with Jordan
in the the Accords with the Palestinians
the Abraham Accords which of course four
other Arab Nations signed with us United
Arab Emirates the kingdom of bahin the
kingdom of Morocco and Sudan they all
signed with us agreements we were moving
forward we had serious ER deliberations
about the possibility of signing a peace
agreement with Saudi Arabia in and
normalization well this attack is part
of a grand scheme to undermine this
process of inclusion doing peace and
turn the region into a region of war and
that is why World Community has to be
forceful and strong and oppose all these
efforts and move strongly towards the
inclusion of Israel in the region while
giving security to Israel and all its
neighbors I commend world leadership I
commend President Joe Biden prime
minister Rishi sunna and the opposition
uh leader starmer and prime minister and
president of France mcon and many others
of course who have stood up with us
against this process of evil and this is
the test of humanity and the entire
world Community these days let me talk
now Mr President about Israel's response
because I wanted to give you enough time
to really explain how you feel as the
president of a country that suffered
that terror attack and you've done so
very evocatively and very
powerly but as you know there is
mounting concern over the the the scale
of is is's response to what happened
many people talking and asking the
question what is proportionate in your
mind is there any response that could be
deemed proportionate or will you do
whatever it takes as a country to
eradicate
Hamas so first let's understand the
rules of international law because most
of the Nations tell us you have the
right to defend yourself we are speaking
about almost 20 years of bombardments
from Gaza on and off ceasefires
agreements operations
Wars while looking for ways and means to
change the equation to war
peace Gaza was taken over in 2017 by
brutal coup of Hamas it was taken out
from the hands of the Palestinians
Palestinian Authority which is
controlled by fat movement and theyve
literally butchered their family members
and took over Hamas and leading it into
a platform of War by Iran they filled it
up with ammunition rather than doing
anything possible to help their own
people and upgrade their living
standards they kept on fighting and
fighting in the last two years there was
progress Israel agreed for the first
time to open up Gaza for gazan employees
to come to work in Israel tens of
thousands of gazans were employed in
Israel and money flowed in they broke
bread and money flowed in and the
economy economy grew little did we
understand
naively that many of those working in
Israel also collected and gathered
information about their
employees
had given information to Kamas as to
where each house is where to land with
your gliders how to break into your
fence and how to get to the cities and
towns in which they worked in and the
money that they they took and they and
all the income from your taxpayers money
for international projects in Gaza was
basically used and taken by Hamas to
build this machine of a of Cruelty and
barbarism let me just say 7th of October
let me just say Mr President I I
completely agree that Hamas should be
eradicated I think most right-minded
people can understand that there can
never be peace now after what Hamas did
on October the 7th but like I say many
people are looking at Israel's response
now nearly 10,000 Palestinians have been
killed since October the 7th these are
figures I must say which are reported by
the Hamas control Palestinian Health
Ministry they say nearly 4,000 children
have been killed we know that uh on
Saturday night the alma refugee camp
which is just to the South uh was bombed
uh reportedly 50 so people let me
explain well well let me ask you on that
one specifically I don't think there's
been a response yet by Israel Hamas say
that was an Israeli air strike is that
true and how do you justify bombing
somewhere that is known to be a refugee
camp we don't I'm not aware of this at
all and a lot there's a lot of fake
coming out of Kamas information channels
but first let me explain to you what we
what what's happening when you have the
right for self-defense you have the
right for self-defense we have been
attacked from people's homes we have
been attacked from schools from mosques
from shops and people's living rooms now
you are your viewers do they have a bomb
do they have a missile do they have a
mortar in their living rooms there are
missile launchers that send missiles 200
km that must be a huge missile I
yesterday tweeted as our forces have
have walked into a theme park and a
playground for children where they found
launchers in the ground ready to launch
missiles on our children and I say
specifically if they are ready to launch
missiles on our children we must go and
eradicate that site same goes for the
houses now how do we behave according to
International humanitarian law we alert
the citizens we tell them in your home
there's a missile launcher get out of
your home go down to the safe Zone in
southern Gaza where you are getting
enough humanitarian Aid and we will
eradicate that infrastructure of Kamas
we sent millions of leaflets we called
and text their messages and whatsapps
and smss and phone calls by 10 million
number Mr President let me people go
down let me just that so at the end at
the end we have to go out and we have to
go in and eradicate that infrastructure
of course we check ourselves with
lawyers and jurists we try to make as
safe as possible not to hurt civilians
and believe me and I say it outright
from the bottom of my heart we care for
every civilian in Gaza I care and I can
tell you stories about me helping Gaz
and citizens all throughout my career
but with all du respect there comes a
moment where you have no other choice
because if we will recur again we'll go
through the same atrocities again but I
understand must eradicated as I said I
absolutely support Israel's right to
defend itself in fact I think you have a
duty as a country uh to and a
responsibility to your people to try and
stop Hamas doing again what they did and
only last week a Hamas spokesman said
that they would try again and again and
again to replicate what happened on
October the 7th so you don't need to
keep telling me how bad herass are I get
it and they have to go it's just how you
do this and that is what is coming under
criticism Queen Ria of Jordan has called
for an immediate ceasefire in a new
interview she says there has to be a
collective call for ceasefire I know
some who are against a ceasefire arguing
it will help Hass however in that
argument they are inherently dismissing
the deaths and in fact endorsing and
justifying the deaths of thousands of
civilians that's not just morally repr
apprehensible shortsighted and not
entirely uh rational if Israel she says
managed to eliminate all of Hamas the
root cause of this conflict is its
illegal occupation and routine human
rights abuses illegal settlements
disregard to un resolutions and
international law if we do not address
the root causes you can kill the
combatant but you cannot kill the cause
what is your response to Queen
Ria
I I don't intend to start arguing with
Ken Ria because I you know I know
exactly uh the considerations and the
limitations of the Jordanian regime
under the circumstances but I would
expect a much better understanding of
the situation on the ground first of all
there must be no justification under any
circumstances none whatsoever to the
atrocities that we have seen and gone
through and no justification ation to
Terror none whatsoever by the way this
hate regime that attacked us the the
first thing they'll do unfortunately
they'll try to attack Jordan as well
we're all in this together they'll try
to attack other regimes as well they're
all in this together We're All in This
Together We Are All Nations who want to
move to peace and we're attacked by this
philosophy of hate of al-Qaeda Isis
Hamas Jihad and the rest they want all
of us out of here and they all want all
of us wiped off and they want a major
Islamic fundamentalist regime throughout
the Middle East that's the real story
and that's the real challenge with all
the respect regarding settlements and
all the these are issues that have been
discussed in a priest process they
should be discussed in a priest process
there are many ideas to have peace with
it between us and the Palestinians and
how to move towards the solutions such
as the two-state solution but it cannot
happen if you support Bo or if you give
any credit in any way directly or
indirectly to Terror we cannot accept
Terror we have to fight teror and then
when we fight teror we can sit down and
talk we tried sitting down and talking
for decades
already remember in the 1990s because in
the 1990s remember in the 1990s tell
suicide bombers killed the process
that's the same like now that's their
tactics that's how they do it but
enti region to fight all I understand
that and I like I say I agree with the
mission statement to get rid of herass
but I share people's concern about the
sheer scale of what is going on in Gaza
not least the mounting humanitarian
crisis you have over a million people
whose homes have been displaced Angelina
Jolie the actress is also a special
Envoy to the un uh High commission for
refugees she said this this is the
deliberate bombing of a trap population
who have nowhere to flee gazra has been
in open air prison for nearly two
decades and is fast becoming a mass
grave 40% of those killed are innocent
children whole families are being
murdered while the world watches and
with the active support of many
governments millions of Palestinian
civilians children women families are
being collectively punished and
dehumanized all while being deprived of
food medicine and humanitarian Aid
against international law by refusing to
demand a humanitarian ceasefire and
blocking the Security Council from
imposing one on both parties world
leaders are complicit in these crimes so
she's saying that you are committing war
crimes here what do you say to
that that I totally reject her claims I
think she's never been in Gaza she's
never been here she never went to visit
and see the facts on the ground with all
the respect people in Gaza know there is
war but there is
no you humanitarian crisis that are not
that that do does not enable them to
survive on the contrary there's a safe
Zone which was agreed by the
International Community in Israel in the
South part of Gaza in order to move the
citizens to that zone to take full care
of them there's a major dramatic
increase in humanitarian Aid to Gaza
which Israel has supported
dramatically in conjunction with the
United States and United Nations and
many other nations the gazan the gazan
people are they can move there so that
we uproot this Terror regime this is
what we know Angel Jolie does not offer
the Israeli people any ability to defend
themselves by saying what she is saying
and may I speak about her comment that
Gaza is a is is a jail Gaza is a jail
not because of Israel Israel pulled out
of Gaza to the last in
Gaza is an Iranian base filled with
Terror smuggled with tons and tons and
tons of ammunition this is the tragedy
that has befallen the gazen people
perhaps the outcome of this war will
enable the gazen people who deserve
decent good life to enjoy it under a
different regime that will enable
movement towards peace part of the
problem further wait wait wait I have to
clear this point with all the respect of
it was Hamas who destroyed the
electricity lines of Gaza by shooting
these missiles it was Hamas who
destroyed the water infrastructure of
Gaza by shooting these missiles Israel
is supplying water Israel is enabling
humanitarian Aid despite the fact that
not one detail came about the hostages
who are there
now in in in Gaza 240 of them
not people are asking themselves time
and again how come with all these
Hypocrites all around the world how come
none of them bother to say you know what
humanitarian Aid give information about
the hostages release the hostages it
can't go this way you'll tell me of
course you know the civilians are not to
blame fine if the civilians are not to
blame then please enable Israel to upro
these terrorists get the mob out of the
city clean the city and enable people to
go back into their Liv will there be any
ceasefire or humanitarian Paws if the
hostages are not
released so first and foremost you know
I'm a head of state I don't enjoy any
executive powers this is under all of
this including the war cabinet is under
the domain of the government the
emergency cabinet the United uh cabinet
of U National Unity under the leadership
for prime minister netan they are
discussing all of this including with
our friends and allies all throughout
the world who understand the the tragedy
understand the challenge and understand
the ideas of how do we aim to get out of
it but we are not dealing with rational
enemies it's not an enemy that you have
certain rules of the Geneva Convention
you are dealing with Psychopaths you are
dealing with a psychopathic leader
who has driven his people into the abyss
unfortunately it's extremely painful let
me tell you I care about Gaz and
children I truly do but with all du
respect first and foremost I have to
defend our people we have to defend the
Israeli Nation we've gone through
atrocities this war was coerced upon us
we did not want to go to war we are not
a war Ming Nation we're a peac loving
Nation you say that mrend our hands
peace again and again we get missiles on
our head and hypocritic comments by
leaders from all around all sorts of
figures from around the world never been
here one day never looked in the eyes of
families who've gone through the worst
of atrocities but let me let me throw
this back at you which is the the
comments of amihai eliahu a far-right
minister in the Israeli government who's
just been suspended after suggesting
Israel may use nuclear weapons against
Gaza that's one way he said that's an
option he also said there are no
non-combatants in Gaza and the
Palestinians should move to Ireland or
the desert those are incredibly incur
and inflammatory remarks and if you're a
Palestinian or if you're an Arab and you
hear a member of Israel's government
talking about nuking Gaza then you think
that there is a callous disregard for
human life in Gaza don't
you so that's a a words of rubbish by
someone who has no No Authority no
knowledge and no involvement in the real
decision making process it is very
regrettable and uh prime minister
nany immediately denied it and took
action H towards this Minister and
called him now to a call where he's
going to explain to him how wrong he is
it is absolutely absurd and nobody
really gives any importance to these
words of
rubbish let's turn to some other words
which I don't think are rubbish but are
certainly
uh worth uh mentioning to you President
Obama the former American president said
the Israeli government's decision to cut
off food water and electricity to a
captive civilian population threatens
not only to worsen the growing
humanitarian crisis it could further
Harden Palestinian attitudes for
Generations erode Global support for
Israel play into the hands of Israel's
enemies and undermined long-term efforts
to achieve peace and stability in the
region and if you want to solve the
problem he says
then you have to take in the whole truth
and you have to admit nobody's hands are
clean all of us are complicit to some
degree do you agree with
him so President Obama I don't know when
he wrote and made that statement because
there is a major supply of food water
and humanitarian Aid to Gaza it flows in
it has been increased dramatically I met
with Secretary of State Tony blinken on
Friday the he met with the Israeli
cabinet he discussed it and there is a
dramatic increase I met with the under
Secretary of the United Nations in is in
my office last week and he thanked
Israel for these enormous humanitarian
steps forward so I think the situation
we which we monitor on an hourly basis
is much more reasonable than you depict
it and yes I don't shy away from the
pains and sufferings of many people but
at the end of it all let's understand
the situation you cannot enable the
Israeli nation which is in shelters to
go to return to the same reality which
was before the 7th of October we cannot
first of all people deserve to go back
to their homes why would they go to
their homes if they know their neighbors
wants to swallow them again teror I
agree with that Mr President so so that
so that that the real issue here is that
I think the International Community
needs to tell all the supporters of
Hamas all the Arab Nations who Express
uh support for Hamas or Arab leaders or
other leaders and tell them you are to
blame you are to blame because you're
enabling this evil regime to come back
again rather than removing the evil
regime finally and enabling a rebuilding
of a h h decent life for the Palestinian
people but you talk about the fact that
Israeli people want to go back to their
homes and of course they do and
absolutely their safety was removed from
them the depravity of October the 7th
has caused huge trauma to not just
people in Israel but Jewish people
around the world I completely get that
but what do gazan people do over a
million have been displaced from their
homes if you could just explain to me
how do the gazan people come back to
their homes if they've all been
obliterated in the north of
Gaza they will be able to re build their
homes like in the past it's not the
first time that they were under War
unfortunately it's extremely tragic but
you don't give me an answer to how
exactly am I going to live with the fact
that in their homes and they and they
saw these missiles from their homes they
saw the terrorists coming out of their
homes they saw the tunnels dug in their
homes they saw their mosque being filled
they saw the hospitals the hospitals
which were financed by so many countries
including EU countries and other
countries become the center of command
of this terror attack this terrorist
organization meaning giving no hope to
them to their children and grandchildren
hopefully when this ends these terrible
circumstances end this horrific
circumstances end we will be able to
offer hope to the Palestinians in Gaza
to go back rebuild their homes and
finally have decent lives with a
different regime that will enable
progress and peace in the region like we
all need to
have final question many people would
agree with you that Hamas has to go
before any peace uh can be achieved but
many people also including many Israelis
according to latest polls believe that
it cannot be achieved with prime
minister nety who's still in office
either many think that what happened on
October the 7th was a catastrophic
failure of security and defense and the
buck should stop stop with him you
yourself have said before about
Netanyahu I'm not sure he has the guts
to do it with regards to moving towards
peace and a two-state solution should
prime minister Netanyahu step
down you know I'm a the head of state as
president of the state the political
system has its own processes I made
clear in a national speech from the
Parliament that they the day after the
war will come where all these issues
will be discussed we are a vibrant
democracy we don't shy away from
anything but right now we're all United
we're all United in one goal we must
return the hostages back we must
overcome and Prevail against our enemies
and we must bring peace and security to
our borders and our peoples this is my
only aim at this point Mr President I
really appreciate you giving me so much
time more than you to and I acknowledge
that and I appreciate it and thank you
very much indeed for joining me today
thank you very
much